it's been 20 years since the death of
the iconic Princess Diana on Thursday
Elton John remembered the late Princess
of Wales with a touching tribute the 70
year old music legend posted a throwback
photo smiling from ear to ear with his
pal captioned twenty years ago today the
world lost an angel it could have faced
in every photograph there's a positive
wonderful love he also shared this snap
of a philanthropic Diana visiting
Hospital patient Gerard McGrath Elton
took a moment to remember Diana's
efforts as an AIDS activist writing in
the caption quote Elton John AIDS
Foundation acknowledges the outstanding
contribution that Princess Diana made to
fight against AIDS helping keep men like
Gerard McGrath alive in the HBO
documentary Diana our mother her life
and legacy
Prince Harry got the chance to meet
Gerard at the London lighthouse and hear
about his mom's one-of-a-kind spirit she
had this incredible ability which he
kind of inherited and I told him that he
would thanks very much actually exceed
people feel it either and make them feel
that everything's gonna be alright
I haven't experienced many people in my
life that had that ability but she could
walk into a room of people and make them
feel as if everything was great
[Music]